[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de revista de
prensa ya está conmigo en el estudio
rosa pérez más de euros a bienvenida a
feliz en miércoles félix mañana vamos a
pensar entonces esa revista de prensa
con una noticia del día hoy se cierra
definitivamente la era mail que merkel
con la investidura de blasco live con él
como el canciller de alemania el nuevo
canciller arrancamos entonces con un
medio británico the gardian olaf scholz
electo para suceder angela merkel como
canciller alemán buenos días raúl
exactamente este medio británico repasa
un poco la figura del que es ya el nuevo
canciller de alemania recuerda que fue
alcalde de la ciudad de hamburgo y que
también fue ministro de finanzas y vice
canciller durante la última legislatura
de merkel en lo que también fue un
ejecutivo de coalición y que ahora llega
al frente de la cancillería
también en un ejecutivo de coalición
pero en este caso con los verdes y con
los liberales que después de las
elecciones del pasado 26 de septiembre y
de haber ya logrado un pacto de gobierno
en el que se han repartido los
ministerios hoy las distintas fuerzas
han investido en el parlamento alemán ya
a olaf scholz puesto al frente del
ejecutivo de este país vamos a ver si se
cumplen pues todas las promesas
expectativas y etcétera así es rosa
vamos ahora desde francia vamos con
lemon olaf scholz un canciller alemán
reconfortante exacto lo que señala el
mont es a través de una crónica que se
remonta hasta junio de 2020 y que narra
un poco las discusiones en el seno del
partido social-demócrata hasta a día de
hoy explica que ha sido el pragmatismo y
la sobriedad lo que ha llevado a olaf
scholz a convencer al electorado que en
mucho caso en muchos casos serán también
electores que habían votado para la ex
canciller angela merkel vamos a ver
también cómo se desarrolla esta figura
raúl y terminamos ya con un medio
nacional
exactamente y hablamos del periódico die
welt que dice hola soles del nuevo
canciller federal exacto y a nivel
profundiza un poco no ya pues interesado
en su propia política nacional explica
pues qué sé del 9º canciller de la
república federal alemana el cuarto que
proviene del partido socialdemócrata y
también explica pues algunos de los
acuerdos a los que ha llegado esta
coalición gubernamental tripartita entre
ellos continuar con la limitación del
precio de los alquileres para promover
la transición energética hacia la
energía verde pero también por ejemplo
armar a drones militares rosa vamos
ahora a nuestro continente el
desconcierto publica un informe
internacional asegura que chile suma 120
años nada menos que es igualdad extrema
rosa exacto de más de un siglo de
desigualdad extrema es un informe que ha
difundido la escuela de economía de
parís y que señala entre otras cosas la
mitad de la población con menos recursos
acumula una riqueza aproximada al 0% del
total mientras que el 1% más rico posee
casi la mitad de ella casi la mitad de
esta riqueza de hecho señala que el 50
por ciento menos rico tiene incluso una
riqueza negativa por la cantidad de
endeudamiento
esta población también señala este
informe que esta desigualdad extrema es
una de las causas de raíz del estallido
social de chile de 2019 que llevó
recordemos a la redacción de esta nueva
carta magna que se está desarrollando en
este momento vamos a ver el draw el
también es un momento pues vital para
chile por de cara a esta segunda vuelta
de las elecciones presidenciales que
tendrá lugar el 19 de diciembre vamos a
ver todo esto cómo se irá
desencadenando y puntualiza para hacer
un enlace con lo que veamos ahora qué
chile acumula niveles de desigualdad muy
parecidos a los de brasil bueno vamos
ahora a terminar con la revista 'time'
porque los electores eligieron
imagínense usted hacia ir bolsonaro como
la persona del año de este 2021 exacto
por esto el vínculo con brasil que
comentábamos pero insistimos esto se
trata de una encuesta que publica la
revista 'time' y en la que sus lectores
deciden cuál es la persona más
influyente del año en su opinión pero no
se trata de la elección que hacen los
editores de la propia revista y el que
acaba ocupando la portada de este medio
de comunicación estadounidense la
elección de los editores la sabremos el
próximo 13 de diciembre ya no la
podremos comentar aquí en directo
américa raúl pero bueno seguro que va a
ser comentada por muchos otros canales
en este caso jair bolsonaro recordemos
en esta encuesta de los electores fue
elegido con el 24 por ciento de los
votos como persona más influyente del
año seguido de donald trump en tercer
lugar el personal médico en primera
línea en 4º alexéi navalni recordemos el
opositor al kremlin encarcelado en rusia
en quinto lugar los científicos que han
desarrollado las vacunas contra el cobat
19 y también pues recordemos que el año
pasado los lectores eligieron al
personal de primera línea entre los que
figuran también los médicos pero también
los repartidores a domicilio o los
trabajadores de supermercados sin
embargo los editores de la revista a
cabo acabaron eligiendo a kamala harris
ya yo byd en rosa gracias por toda la
información